I gotta ask you about the a game I  haven't played but people put up there  as one of the greats Zelda breath of the  wild have you gotten a chance to play a  lot of it yes yes it's fantastic it's  fantastic what do you think about I mean  it's a very different experience I  played other zeldas than the open walls  you've created but it is also an open  world it is uh uh it's my favorite Zelda  because obviously like open World stuff  and  the the one thing that they do really  really well is they don't constrain you  some people you know even some things we  do can strain you a little bit more  Zelda says here's the whole thing  and you are constrained by the actual  um player abilities you haven't earned  yet not some arbitrary barriers and so I  think they just did a phenomenal job  it's a magical game  it really feels open it's because it  truly is yes